[Music]
9th of October gentle breezes and clear
weather p.m. stood into the bay and
anchored on the northeast side before
the entrance of a small river intend
fathoms fine sandy bottom the northeast
point of the bay bought east by south
half south and the southwest point to
south distance from the shore half a
league after this I went to Shan with a
party of men in the boat and you'll
accompanied by mr. banks and dr.
cylinder we landed abreast of the ship
and on the east side of the river just
mentioned but seeing some of the natives
on the other side of the river of whom I
was desirous of speaking with and
finding that we could not Ford the river
I ordered the y'all in to carry us over
and the boat to lay off at the entrance
in the meantime the Indians made of
however we went as far as their huts
which lay about two or three hundred
yards from the waterside leaving for
boys to take care of the Ewell which we
had no sooner left then four men came
out of the woods on the other side of
the river and would certainly have cut
her off
had not the people in the boat
discovered them and called to her to
drop down the stream which they did
being closely pursued by the Indians
the Coxon of the boat who had the charge
over the boats seeing this fired two
muskets over their heads the first made
them stop and look round but the second
they took no notice of upon which a
third was fired and killed one of them
upon the spot just as he was going to
dart his spear at the boat this the
other three stood motionless for a
minute or two seemingly quite surprised
wondering no doubt what it was that had
thus killed their comrade but as soon as
they recovered themselves they made off
dragging the dead body a little way and
then left it upon our hearing the report
of the muskets we immediately prepared
to the boats and after viewing the dead
body
we returned on board in the morning
seeing a number of the natives at the
same place where we saw them last night
I went on shore with the boats manned
and armed and landed on the opposite
side of the river mr. banks dr. cylinder
and myself only landed at first I went
to the side of the river
the natives being got together on the
opposite side we called to them in the
Georges island language but they
answered us by flourishing their weapons
over their heads and dancing as we
supposed the war danced upon this we
retired until the marines were landed
which i ordered to be drawn up about two
hundred yards behind us we went again to
the river side having to pierre mr.
green and doctor Monkhouse along with us
to be as spoke to them in his own
language and it was an agreeable
surprise to us to find that they
perfectly understood him after some
little conversation had passed one of
them swam over to us and after him
twenty or thirty more these last brought
their arms which the first man did not
we made them everyone presence but this
did not satisfy them they wanted
everything that we had about us
particularly our arms and made several
attempts to snatch them out of our hands
Dhupia told us several times as soon as
they came over to take
care of ourselves but they were not our
friends and this we very soon found for
one of them snatched mr. Greene's hanger
from him
and would not give it up this encouraged
the rest to be more insolent and seeing
others coming over to join the my or did
the man who had taken the hanger to be
fired at which was accordingly done and
wounded in such a manner that he died
soon after upon the first fire which was
only two muskets the others retired to a
rock which lay nearly in the middle of
the river but on seeing the man fall
they returned probably to carry him off
for his arms the last of which they
accomplished and this we could not
prevent unless we had run our bayonets
into them for upon their returning to
the rock we had discharged off our
pieces which are loaded with small shot
and wounded three more but these got
over the river and were carried off by
the others who now thought proper to
retire finding nothing was to be done
with the people on this side and the
water in the river being sawed I
embarked with an intent to row round the
head of the bay in search of some fresh
water and if possible to surprise some
of the natives and to take them on board
and buy good treatment and presents
endeavour to gain their friendship with
this view
Tuesday the 10th p.m. I rode around the
head of the bay but could find no place
to land on account of the great surf
which beat everywhere upon the shore
seeing two boats or canoes coming in
from the sea I rowed to one of them in
order to seize upon the people and came
so near before they took notice of us
the tupaea called to them to come
alongside and we would not hurt them but
instead of doing this they endeavored to
get away upon which I will did a musket
to be fired over their heads thinking
this would either make them surrender or
jump overboard but here I was mistaken
for they immediately took to their arms
or whatever they had in the boat and
began to attack us this obliged us to
fire upon them and unfortunately either
two or three were killed and one wounded
and three jumped overboard
these last we took up and brought on
board where they were clothed and
treated with all imaginable kindness and
to the surprise of everybody at once
became as cheerful than as merry as if
they had been with their own friends
there were all three young the eldest
not above twenty years of age and the
youngest about ten or twelve I am aware
that most humane men who have not
experienced things of this nature will
censor my conduct in firing upon the
people in their boat nor do I myself
think that the reason I had for seizing
upon her will at all
justify me and had I've thought that
they would have made the least
resistance I would not have come near
them but as they did I was not to stand
still and suffer either myself all those
that were there with me to be knocked on
the head
you
[Music]